- I would do my best to
try to convince people,
as much as possible.
I think the more we yell at each other,
the more we try to shame each other,
the more resistance we get from those
who we're trying to influence
and I just think, in this regard,
for the sake of our
country we need to do this
because our politics has
deteriorated to a very low point
and it's one of the things that
really keeps me up at night
because throughout the
world I think we've seen
how this deterioration
and social decay can end
and it never ends in a good place.
Look, the truth is, that the system set up
by our founding fathers
is not meant to act fast.
Paul Ryan had a great line the other day.
He said, "I run a coalition government
without the efficiencies
of a parliamentary system."
For a comparative politics class,
but that's what we have
and we have two chambers.
This huge board of directors
split in half, 435 and 100.
It's difficult and a lot of this work
has to be done one by
one and that's how I work
with my colleagues, one by one.
I sit with them and I say,
"Look, this is what's happening,
this is the group we formed,
this is the purpose of it.
There are no surprises here.
We're gonna try to
everything by consensus.
We want you to bring your ideas."
And that's how we've
gotten from zero to 62.
And we've just gotta keep climbing.